the United States is putting more
pressure on Iran in a bid to drive
Terrence exports to zero the State
Department is expected to announce the
end of waivers for countries to import
Iranian oil today Monday according to a
newspaper report the waivers will end on
the 2nd of May
now all prices rallied for about 3% on
the news with Brent crude reaching more
than 70 3.86 US dollars a barrel now
removing the sanctions extensions would
reduce all supply from a market that is
already tight because of US sanctions
against Iran and fellow OPEC member
Venezuela before Washington reinforced
sanctions against Iran last year Tehran
produced around 2.3 million barrels of
oil per day that's around 5 percent of
global output up until now
Washington had granted some importing
nations waivers on the oil sanctions
China and India are the biggest buyers
of Iranian crude recently they have
stepped up their oil imports along with
South Korea Italy and Greece on the
other hand have managed to cut their
demand turkey had been fighting until
the last moment for an extension of the
sanctions waivers despite the sanctions
Iran's oil exports are said to have
increased around 12 percent by the end
of March but it's hard to say how true
that figure is Iran is trying to veil
the exact amount by making good use of
its a Marta of oil tankers the
second-largest fleet in the world